it's great to be joined today by Douglas
Lane who's the publisher of the critical
theory imprint zero books a podcaster
and youtuber and the author of several
novels most recently his critically
acclaimed novel bash bash revolution
which came out in March of this year
which we will get to it's so great to
have you on you know we you like we have
been following the pseudo-intellectual
ism movement that has really become
extraordinarily popular over the last
several years and I think it's important
to understand the movement to go back
beyond just the last sort of several
years where do you really pinpoint as as
the sort of origin of what we now see as
pseudo intellectual ISM like how far
back does this phenomena go oh well I
mean if you want to go all the way back
it goes to the previous pre-socratic you
know rhetorician x'
the you know the Sophos if people who
think that argument sounding good and
being rhetorically effective or better
or just as good anyway as sound
arguments um but as far as the new kind
of classical liberal anti social justice
warrior movement with people like dave
rubin and jordan peterson and even sam
harris to a degree it's it's really
tough to say that for me actually win
that exactly started certainly before
the election of Trump there's been a
move to critique the last as being
regressive to critique the left as
allergic to debate and sometimes that's
not entirely wrong sure but but the the
problem is that by becoming victims
themselves of this regressive left they
stopped being interested in actually
having those debates and they're just
sort of scoring easy points off of these
incidents where young leftist usually or
academics will you know duck out of
debate or claim to
that rigorous debate would be offensive
or something and so they do the same
thing but in Reverse
but yeah I would say that 2014 might be
the beginning somewhere around there
where you start to see this building up
of what I'll just call an
anti-intellectual right but but that or
an anti social justice warrior right
certainly one of the things I've
experienced when talking about this is I
will sometimes and you know you
mentioned some names and I now I'm
increasingly careful not to unless I'm
offering sort of like a specific
criticism of a particular idea because
most of the feedback I get from the
audience is basically arguing about
whether the specific individuals I
mentioned are or aren't intellectuals
and I feel that that's actually a
distraction from what the issue really
is I'm more concerned with the pseudo
intellectualism of the movement that has
been built around the individuals and
less so about the sort of intellectual
credentials of any one particular person
I'm curious whether you agree or whether
you think the focus actually should be
on the intellectual credentials of any
particular individual yeah no I totally
agree and actually you know I'm not
doubting the credentials of say Jordan
Peterson right I mean he's a professor
he has a he's a clinical psychologist he
has his level of expertise I'm sure he's
more educated about Union psychology
than I am and I don't want to impugn his
reputation as a professor I think anyone
who is a public intellectual I might be
tempted to kind of become a pseudo
intellectual because the market drives
you to simplify your message to find
what communicates well and to placate
and you know comfort your audience so
whenever you're not looking at difficult
questions or avoiding debates within
either internally or with a foe you know
an ideological opponent you're probably
engaging in some sort of pseudo
intellectual ism you're probably using
rhetorical arguments when you should be
you know thinking
I've made the analogy that some of what
makes these pseudo intellectual ideas
appealing to individuals who sort of
follow them and start to espouse and
parrot them is similar to what makes
conspiracy theories appealing to people
sometimes which is that there is some
way in which having a seemingly
straightforward and supposedly objective
explanation of how and why something
happened or how and why something is the
way that it is is in a way more
comforting than acknowledging the
significant gray area that exists in
most areas of sort of human existence as
a species on our planet and and while of
course the pseudo intellectualism stuff
is not conspiracy theories I'm not
saying that that some of the psychology
underlying its appeal has cross over
cross over do you what do you think of
that do you think there's something
there I needed yeah absolutely I think
that actually one of the common traits
of I like to call them the anti social
justice warrior personalities they're
part of an industry of media industry
that's risen up one of the common tropes
is this trope that the difficulties that
we are experiencing say in our family
life you know in the family in America
is in crisis that this is due to bad
actors this is due to like say for
instance hysterical feminists and then
that that movement itself is due to a
conspiracy a conspiracy by Marxists to
undermine Western civilization so you
can find I don't forget post modernists
as well
right well post-modernism right as well
which is again just a you know a cover
ideology for the true evil of Marxism I
happen to be what I call a wannabe
Marxist which means that I've read Marx
on crime struggling to understand his
work as deeply as I can and I do think
that he has a very powerful critique of
capitalism and the structure of our
society around class lines
I am particularly interested in and kind
of combating this conspiracy theory in
the anti social justice warrior industry
for me that's the most important thing
that they're doing and that's for two
reasons one is that it's wrong and it's
red baiting and it needs to be combated
but the other reason is it because every
time they do that it gives a Marxist
like myself an opportunity to correct
them and to talk about what marks
actually wrote and to kind of push my
own propaganda there so I think that's
the most example actually because one of
the sort of trends that I'm seeing is
that the this movement however it is
that we describe it in whatever borders
we sort of assigned to it is actually
very effective at creating no-win
situations for their would-be opponents
in the sense that they set up scenarios
where if I is someone on the left for
example say listen there is an anti free
speech element on the left but I think
that it's very small I'm immediately
interrupted in its oh so you admit that
it exists right and then that's sort of
where the conversation follows and it
appears as a sort of some pseudo
vindication the the other the only other
way is to sort of deny that there's any
element of truth to it which is not
actually authentically what I think and
they've really set it up very well to be
able to say either way whether you
accept that they're right or whether the
whether you deny it you fall into this
sort of caricature of what they're
criticizing and I wonder if you have any
idea how to sort of circumvent that I
don't know the only I can think of doing
is trying to get them to live up to
their own rhetoric and propaganda and
the way their own self conception you
know Jordan Peterson can be quite
eloquent about defending free speech and
how important it is to be able to
articulate ideas and talk together in
public to figure out what we should do
as a society and he's not wrong I mean
when he talks about that
he's compelling um and but he doesn't do
it and I want to give you my own
particular example yeah I know about
this and I think it'll
interesting yeah so back in December of
last year I emailed Jordan Peterson's
publicist and asked for an interview
with Petersen telling them that we are a
critical theory imprint out of the UK
and that I wanted to discuss Nietzsche
and Marx with him and I gave him a few
other details I gave her his publicist a
few other details they gave me a date
they said sure what's make this happen
along the right around the time when his
book is coming out so you know had it
down for January 24th I was very excited
I announced it on Facebook and on
Twitter and all of that and I have to
say there were elements of the left
people who I knew and people who at
least I knew of who were very critical
of me for even giving Peterson a
platform but I insisted you know that we
had to you know engage with the right
that we couldn't just think that we
could socially shame ordy platform away
bad ideas and that we should engage them
so this was scheduled his team canceled
right after or right around the time
that the Kathy Newman interview happened
and that the reason they canceled was
because after that Kathy Newman
interview in which by the way I think
she did a particularly poor job of
engaging him because she misrepresented
his ideas in real time I mean not that
his ideas are great but you don't and
you don't have to misrepresent them you
just have to engage them but in any case
they cancelled and shortly after that
you know they promised to reschedule but
they canceled shortly after that he went
on to a Rogen and said no Marxist would
ever debate him Rogen Aston you you know
have you ever talked to these crazy
people you know what have you ever heard
their side of the story what do they say
and he said well no they don't debate me
they did they don't wanted to be they
never asked me and that was when I
decided well wait a minute there you
know I have to intervene somehow so I
started tweeting at him and saying hey
we have a you know an interview plan
you're not you know you're not telling
the truth you know rule eight what about
rule eight always speak the truth I mean
we correct you I know you might be
mistaken here but so then then has
teamed shortly after that not too long
after that just canceled altogether
saying there would never be a time for
us to talk and so now I don't know if
that was in response to my tweets I
would tend to think knock I just tend to
think you know he was getting bigger and
bigger and bigger and he started going
on his world tour and and they just
cleared the board of all the smaller
shows so but in any case I said hey wait
you know we had an agreement before you
know this isn't like a new request
you're treating this like it's a new
request that they didn't write back to
me and then recently on Reddit he did
this ask me anything
I'm not exactly sure what to call it you
know but you people have so many
questions she read it and he responded
on Reddit and one of the questions asked
is why are you ducking Douglas Lane why
haven't you debated Douglas Lane you
know you say no Marxist wants to debate
you but he invited you want to show and
you cancelled so how can you say that
and he gave a kind of angry response
it's like I'm not obligated to talk to
just anybody who asks and you know I
don't know who Douglas Lane is and I
never heard about this and so ok so he
didn't hear about it from his publicist
I believe that and he's not obligated to
talk to me but now by his own rule he is
obligated to stop saying that no marks
this one right and I'm gonna be watching
to see if he continues to say that if I
had the resources I'd make a little
movie like Roger and me what join
Pearson I just follow him trying to get
that interview and mica you know and
Michael Moore chased down the head of
General Motors yes to talk to him so I
would do that with Peterson if I if I
had the resources but I don't had too
many hands or things to do but I will
pursue him on social media I guess and
and try to hold him to his own rule rule
8 which is always tell the truth
and now we know that he knows that
there's a Marxist who wants to debate it
let's pause our conversation there were
with Douglas Lane and we are going to
continue the conversation with him on
tomorrow's program we're continuing our
conversation with Douglas Lanie's the
publisher of the critical theory imprint
zero books podcaster youtuber author of
several novels including most recently
bash bash revolution which we will get
to shortly Douglas what's your sense of
when it comes to fighting pseudo
intellectual ism and not that
necessarily the individuals but the
ideas what's the best way to engage some
of the people that hear one of these
pseudo intellectual memes and then they
start to integrate it into their sort of
normal repertoire of debate and
discussion what's the best way to take
the ideas head-on and challenge them you
know I I happen to like bring a prop to
answer that question and this is a
Christopher Lashes book the culture of
narcissism and what I think the best way
to to I think the best way to go about
combatting someone like Peterson is to
first of all point out that there are
left critics who make similar but not
identical arguments to his that we
should engage with and that we should
take on and talk about and and I think
Christopher lash will be that kind of
critic I mean he was writing in the 70s
and 80s and 90s he's long dead now but a
lot of what he said about the crisis of
in of the family and its critiques of
liberal modernity and his concerns about
the American culture kind of are echoed
in Peterson's talk and I mean Peterson's
much more shallow thinker and that's why
it's a good idea to point out that not
only can we engage with Peterson but we
have our own critics of these phenomena
these problems and so that's what I
would suggest people do is because it
doesn't go run the risk I'm curious
whether that runs the risk of you know
Peterson likes to insist that he is not
an all right guy and that his ideas are
not fundamentally right wing ideas and
that's one of the defenses he uses
actually when he's critique doesn't that
risk allowing him to get away with that
even more when it's often sort of a
distort
in terms of the solutions because I feel
like you're right that there are lots of
other people on left and right who
identify similar problems to the ones he
identifies but the solutions is often
where there's a difference well I'm not
sure about how important it is to peg
him as alt right yeah I don't think it
is that important but it'sit's because
it's often a topic of discussion I guess
I bring it up yeah yeah I mean I I think
that more important than pegging him is
all right is to create a situation where
his ideas are not the only ones out
there and not the only ones resonating
with people who might be feeling
pressures around say employment or
family trouble or coming of age I mean I
think that's a very big part of his
appeal is that you've got young men in
particular who are having difficulties
maybe finding a job and certainly
finding themselves as a transition from
being kids to adults and Peterson's
giving them not only a way to to try to
think about doing that but also people
to blame for their own problems
and if you can give them a way to
understand their situation that's a
little deeper that might cut against his
appeal so I like developing our own
critiques putting forward our own ideas
and being willing to take on
difficulties within our own ideology I
think of some there really are some some
problems in on the left right now the
fact that Trump won is not just a
symptom of how bad the Rust Belt is or
how bad certain segments of Americans
are but also how there's a crisis in
liberal politics and we've lost our way
to it to an extent and we need to
rediscover our mission and those others
need to be eloquent though right I mean
a lot of it is packaging and PR and the
presentation and so even if we identify
competing ideas or similar critiques
that maybe approach solutions
differently you need someone who can do
what Peterson does as well
well that's you right I got this show
you've got you've got no but seriously I
mean there's a cult of personality
element to it that should not be
understated yeah okay that's true and I
don't know exactly what to do about that
and the the thing about that is that
doesn't just happen on the right and it
doesn't it doesn't happen quite as often
on you know for liberal political shows
like say this one or the majority or for
no one's doing you know setting up an
altar to Sam Seder right but but it does
happen online some it happens to anyone
who comes along and says hey I have a
way for you to make sense of your life
and like I think if Peterson in
particulars being kind of a similar
character to Terence Mckenna who was you
know totally different ideologically but
it had a similar kind of appeal to
people because they could turn to
McKenna who has some wild ideas crazy
ideas but he also spoke well and
developed a little cult of personality
around himself and and you know it's
like a pop star they also have they
develop fan bases right so I'm not sure
how to deal with that exactly
I know that you know we did we don't we
do it sometimes on the left I mean Noam
Chomsky is a hero to a lot of people
he's it's unlikely up star so yeah I
don't know exactly what to do about that
I mean just don't be too allergic to it
but be aware of the problem let's talk a
little bit if we can to talk about to go
from a real life dystopia maybe to one
that pseudo fictional I guess your
latest book bash bash revolution yeah it
is it is dystopian it relates to a whole
that one up sure by all means yeah tell
us a little bit I mean what how do you
describe the book sorry I lost you there
is no problem I mean how did you
conceive of the book how did you
describe how do how would you describe
the book to people well okay so the book
was written for two reasons one is that
my son is very good at super smash
brothers melee he's in college now but
when I started it out he was younger and
and he could always beat me at super
smash brothers melee so I decided I
wanted to write a novel it was like a
wish fulfillment novel where the
middle-aged dad could win and the only
way I could think of doing it is that he
would get help from an AI so that was
part of the reason I wrote the book but
that's not actually the major plot
points in the book it's about trying to
conceive of a way to overcome capitalism
and it's sort of a thought experiment
novel where I set up a situation where
with help from an from artificial
intelligence a gang of gamers save the
world by overcoming capitalism but along
the way lose their identities and lose
their sense of connectedness and one of
them the main character starts out the
novel resisting being part of the new
economy the revolution but what's called
the gamecube economy and so it's written
from this point of view of at the center
against the very thing that's stopping
society from being destroyed by the
trump administration and the nuclear
Armageddon and all of that so that's the
plot of that then that's a summary of
bash mass revolution so this is like a
very practical question but I've not yet
gotten a good answer to it and since
you're in the genre maybe you can tell
me what is the difference between
accessible science fiction and young
adult science fiction I don't know I my
book has been marketed as young adult
but I didn't write it with that aim it
does have a innate protagonist I'm not
put off by that but it is interesting to
me that that's where it ended up
I guess I'm really I think the
difference is just marketing I think
that and also maybe like I said maybe
it's just whether or not there are young
characters that you know protagonists
dominate the story that might be all it
is but I do know that there are people
in the genre who really focus on writing
young adult novels that are thoughtful
and interesting and and aimed
specifically at those readers and I
didn't do that but I ended up in that
category present company aside of course
what's your assessment of the science
fiction world right now I mean it's very
easy to just say hey listen the greats
are in the past and this is not the best
time for science fiction but you know
ever anybody can just say that I mean
when you really think about it like what
do you think about the current era of
science fiction well I don't know I
think the great stir in the past and
know um I like I like a number of
writers who are working today and I
think it's really exciting when people
who have though I've known you know
maybe not well but I've known of a new
we've met at conventions and things
succeed and so I'm a little jealous of
people like Jeff Vandermeer and Ted
Chiang who had movies made of their work
and have had big work and I would say
that in a lot of ways that the science
fiction writing that's going on today is
more significant in the overall culture
than it ever has been because it has
bled well into the mainstream of you
know our culture so someone like
stranger things that's a science fiction
story right I mean that's all that is
and it's it was a huge phenomenon and
and you didn't have to be a nerd to be
into it so I think science fiction is
bigger than ever as terms of like short
story writing and even novel writing the
the whole realm of publishing is
changing so much that it's difficult to
say where the center is anymore
you don't have a one set of writers who
everyone knows anymore the I mean there
are a few that a lot of people know like
the enemy but there there's no center
anymore it solved niched out and and
kind of Macra micro-targeted
micro-targeted
so the other thing is I sort of I was
going to science fiction conventions and
really participating in that culture a
lot about a decade ago and a couple
years back now
in 2015 I was nominated for a science
fiction award called the philip k dick
award so i went to a convention again
and then it when I was there I realized
oh I haven't been to a convention in a
very long time no I know no one here
so it's yeah I don't know if that just
speaks to me or something's changing in
the science fiction world because I
could still write science fiction and
not participate in that culture as much
and it may mean I think but I don't know
that it may mean that that sort of
convention going right short stories and
get published and then write novels
industry is just dying and the internet
is just replace but we used to think of
it's a science fiction culture well
that's depressing but you should still
check out Douglas Lanes latest novel
bash bash revolution Douglas thanks so
much for talking to me today
yeah thanks for having me on